[Musique]
washington dc la capitale des états unis
d'amérique
une ville propre une ville riche une
ville de pouvoir à quelques kilomètres
des édifices étincelant du congrès la
réalité est moins reluisant le quartier
noir
dana kostia reste un des plus pauvres de
washington ricky johnson 60 ans et
héroïnomane
il consomme depuis l'adolescence
ce matin là lui qui fait le plein de
seringue propre dans cette roulotte
l'héroïne dit-il lui procure du
bien-être en 2017
washington dc devient la capitale des
surdoses mortelles
c'est l'hécatombe 279 morts causées par
l'héroïne mélangés aux fenton il un
opioïde d'une puissance inouïe
peyrens cooper travail à la roulotte qui
distribue seringue et médicaments pour
contrôler les overdoses
il apprend la mort de ses clients toutes
les semaines jean 55 ans a vu elle aussi
des proches marie guy gina se drogue à
l'héroïne depuis 40 ans elle tente de se
défaire de sa dépendance
le docteur edwin chapman mène une guerre
contre le fentanyl qui s'est immiscé
dans la vie des héroïnomanes les hommes
noirs en sont les premières victimes
il se bat contre l'incompétence des
autorités qui dit-il se sont traîné les
pieds
il a mis en place un programme pour
traiter l'accoutumance à l'héroïne
alvin norge consomme lui depuis 20 ans
on vient de lui prescrire du sceau
bocson un médicament pour ces période de
sevrage nous ce n'est ni le combat
contre les opioïdes à washington dc
passe également par le bureau de barbra
bestron elle rejette les accusations
d'incompétence à l'endroit de la ville
promet 65 millions de dollars pour le
district de columbia
elle veut réduire le nombre de morts de
50% d'ici l'an prochain
ailleurs au pays le fentanyl dessus
surtout sous forme de pilules
des devises mais en attendant les
solutions à la crise
wiki jones une voie encore des amis
mourir
au menu tous les mairies to mail
s'extirper des griffes de l'héroïne et
des opioïdes est un enfer une bataille
dit jean à benjamines difficile à gagner
[Musique]
la sur consommation d'héroïne et
d'opioïdes a tué plus de 70000 américain
en 2007 seulement le drame humain dont
on ne voit pas encore la fin
[Musique]